>>> NOW RERETURN TO OUR FEATURE
PRESENTATION, THE DOLPHIN WHO
LEARNED TO SPEAK.
>> IN THE 1960s, THERE WAS A
GROUND SWELL OF SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH INTO THE MINDS OF
ANIMALS.
THE MALLAL COGNITION LAB WAS
PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON DOLPHIN
COMMUNICATIONS.
>> WE WERE A TWO-WOMAN TEAM
EAGER TO PROVE OURSELVES IN THE
MALE MALE DOMINATED FIELD OF
SCIENCE.
>> OUR OBJECTIVE WAS SIMPLE, CAN
DOLPHINS ACQUIRE HUMAN LANGUAGE?
WHAT IF A DOLPHIN COULD SPEAK?
>> MAY 7th, 1965.
>> OUR SPECIMEN WAS A
15-YEAR-OLD MALE NAMED GERALD.
HE WAS VERY SMART, VERY STRONG
WILLED.
>> A.
SEE MY MOUTH.
A.
GERALD.
>> BUT AS GERALD REACHED
BREEDING AGE, HE BECAME LESS
FOCUSED.
AGITATED.
HIS NATURAL DRIVE WAS
DISTRACTING HIM FROM OUR WORK.
>> YOU KNOW, WHEN A DOLPHIN
REACHES SEXUAL MATURITY, THERE
IS NO STOPPING THEM.
AND THEN ONE DAY I WAS IN THE
WATER WITH GERALD WHEN HE GOT
THAT GLASSY LOOK IN HIS EYE THAT
MEANT HE WAS HAVING AN URGE, SO
TO SPEAK.
AND SO I TURNED TO MARY AND I
SAID WHY DON'T I JUST YANK HIM
OFF REAL QUICK?
JUST LIKE THAT.
IT JUST CAME OUT.
>> AT FIRST I WASN'T SURE IT WAS
ETHICAL BUT WE HAD TO, FOR THE
SCIENCE.
>> SO I DID IT.
HEY.
RIGHT AWAY, YOU KNOW, HE WAS
CLEAR AS A BELL AND WE WERE ABLE
TO QUICKLY GET BACK TO OUR WORK.
>> YES.
AND SO IT BECAME PART OF OUR
ROUTINE.
WE WOULD WORK A WHILE, YANK A
WHILE, WORK A WHILE, YANK A
WHILE, THEN A TUG OR TWO AND
THEN TEACH A DOLPHIN TO SPEAK.
>> THEIR METHODS WERE UNORTHODOX
AND THEIR COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE LAB BEGAN TAKE
NOTICE.
>> I WAS ON THE ECHO LOCATION
UNIT ACROSS THE HALL.
WE KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING IN
THERE.
I WROTE ABOUT IT IN MY FIELD
NOTES.
APRIL 21st, 1965.
NO, NO, NO, THAT'S NASTY.
ALL OF YOU ARE NASTY.
SICK PEOPLE, YANKING OFF THAT
FISH.
HELL NO.
>> FOR A WHILE THE PROGRESS WAS
ASTOUNDING.
HE LEARNED THE ALPHABET.
>> A.
>> WE WERE ABLE TO TEACH HIM
SIGN LANGUAGE.
BUT SOON HE STARTED TO REGRESS.
REALLY ONLY DOING A FEW SIGNS.
THE SIGNS FOR HAND, AND NOW, AND
WHO GONNA J ME O, AND HURRY, AND
>> FISH, WATER.
>> I'M PRETTY SURE GERALD WAS
TALKING TO THE OTHER DOLPHINS
AND TELLING THEM, HEY, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORK FOR FISH.
THEY WILL DO OTHER THINGS.
>> EVENTUALLY, THE HAND SESSIONS
TOOK UP MOST OF THE TIME.
>> ALMOST SEVEN TO EIGHT HOURS
OF THE DAY.
LATER I SUGGESTED A WAY OF
WORKING AS A TEAM, TO SORT OF
SPEED UP THE PROCESS.
WHEN SHE WAS THE HAND I WOULD
WOULD WAIT OUTSIDE THE DOOR, I
WOULD COUNT TO 20, I WOULD BUST
IN AND SAY WHO IS DOING NASTY
THINGS IN HERE?
BAD GERALD.
GERALD REALLY LIKED SHAME.
AND THIS WAS GOOD, OF COURSE FOR
THE SCIENCE.
>> BUT AFTER TEN YEARS OF WORK
WITH GERALD HE WAS APPROVED FOR
A WELL DESERVED RETIREMENT FROM
THE RESEARCH LAB.
>> IT WAS HARD TO SAY GOOD-BYE
TO GERALD, PHYSICALLY, BECAUSE
HE WAS FRANTICALLY TRYING TO
TURN IT INTO A SEX THING.
EVENTUALLY THEY CLEARED GERALD
FOR RELEASE INTO THE WILD.
BUT BOY, DO I STILL THINK OF HIM
FONDLY.